hey i'm andy haynes and i'm here to
answer the internet
have you ever dated a person you banged
on the first
or second date and i have dated all of
them because i'm
mentally ill and if i have sex with you
i'm like this is the one
she stole my metro card and gave me an
std but there's something about this
lady
would you do seven minutes in heaven
with caitlyn jenner to have sex with
kendall jenner
uh yeah why not i'm gonna
that's the whole thing like everybody
like is like i i feel like dudes are
like would you [ __ ] this
you know like or like how much would
they pay you to have sex
i would [ __ ] a lot of male celebrities
just for the story
are you kidding me like i was talking
about this with a friend
like i'd [ __ ] dmx
[Laughter]
you're gonna call me gay for [ __ ] dmx
[Laughter]
are you kidding me [ __ ] x is the
strangest guess
you wouldn't be like oh do your auntie
[ __ ] skies you'd be like andy [ __ ]
dmx
i would just ask her about the olympics
seven minutes discussing the 1984
election yeah
just jerking off her disaster of a [ __ ]
is this good for you what was it like
when you got on the podium
[Laughter]
uh is it weird to 69 with random people
yeah very because i mean like not like
it's
fun sometimes but sometimes you get down
there and you realize that you had a
totally wrong angle
it's a [ __ ] is very different when you
approach it straight on than when you
approach it upside down
yeah gravity does different things you
haven't your nose is in their [ __ ]
now now you really know
the extent of their hygiene
how long before you 69 with someone is
normal
don't i mean it's for me that's always
novelty that's always like wow we're
[ __ ]
we haven't done this yet okay also i'm
38 like i'm not
just like coming you know what i mean
i have to [ __ ] focus and i'm thinking
about a woman i saw struggling with a
suitcase on the subway today you know
like
there's no way i'm just like wow this
feels great oops gonna come
you know like i'm like ah you know like
but it takes a lot of effort yeah
professor x
trying to locate wolverine you know
[Laughter]
the last the last question was um it was
uh have you ever made up
what's the best story you've made up to
hook up with somebody
and um it it wasn't a story it was that
when i got on raya when i was single um
you're not on it
that's insane it's the best
the worst people are on there but
um the when i was on raya um so
sometimes like i'll pick i
i would pick up uh money by working at
this moving company
just like doing like moves and it's all
cash it was easy
good work out and um so i was like on a
job and i told this girl what i was
doing and she just cut me off
she was like [ __ ] mover are you
kidding me gross you know it was like
some
cnn correspondent or something like that
you know she was just like i'm not
having anything to do with you and i was
like fair game
uh but then the next time a girl asked
me what i was doing
i was like oh i like restore furniture
and then deliver it and she was like
that is so [ __ ] hot and i was like
you
evil [ __ ] this one is what's the
weirdest thing you've said to a person
in the middle of sex and i think
um it was
the dog is licking my foot
[Laughter]
because the dog was licking my foot
our puppy i was like laying on the bed
post coitus
and the puppy came by and swiped the
dick
came by and got a [ __ ] swipe and i
was like what the i have to [ __ ] go
for a walk i gotta call
my sponsor my [ __ ] priest i'm not
even catholic
it was one of those like it was like we
were having sex doggy stuff so it wasn't
even one of those like whoa what did she
do like i knew four officers
[Laughter]
a beautiful shepherd you're like i'm in
big fat
[ __ ] bulldog [ __ ] out of here bro
if you got a stat sheet about your life
what three things would you want to know
um am i gonna die indoors
like you know because i i don't want to
die in some kind of children amen
refugee camp you know where like i got
sent there because i like could read or
something like that
um okay
uh uh can i
have a picture of alexander d'addario
naked that's not a statute thing but i
still just like
can i just trade out one of those for
that
and um i don't want to know time i feel
like it would be too hard to know
like when you're gonna die so i'd be
like
uh oh am i ever gonna go fully bald
you know what i mean like how long can i
keep the facade going
or do i have to fly to turkey and get
this done
what would be the most embarrassing way
to die within the confines of your
average day
um i mean i think it's always like super
embarrassing when those like dudes
in like uh shootouts or like movies that
involve guns they like trip and
shoot themselves in the head um
no but i'm trying to think of like it
would be something like that it would be
something like um
it would be like uh tripping and then
like falling into the subway
yeah you know what i mean like falling
oh you just he just was a spaz
like you just tripped and fell and
you're dead now yeah like one of those
trips where you try to save it but you
move forward too much i'd be like going
up the subways i'm like probably
listening to like music i shouldn't be
and i think i look cool in some kind of
like hype beast outfit
you know what i mean like i pretend i'm
like i'm just like you guys don't even
get it i'm listening to a little baby
and i'm in [ __ ] exactly what i'm
supposed to be wearing
you probably think i'm rich you guys
people probably recognize me from that
comedy central digital thing i did and
then i just
hit the top step and i'm like whoa whoa
whoa and then i'm just
meat grinder you know
i think it would also be hard to um
i'd be pretty embarrassed if i died
[ __ ] you know
my my grandpa died [ __ ] like he
pressed too hard you know
yeah you can do that like a vasovagal
response like you
i think rosewood actually used that term
when she did it it's like when your body
just like panics and shuts down it's
like a shock thing you know
but if you're old your body's like hey
we don't really shut down well you know
yeah so he's like pressing and he just
went
out i don't know and that's the thing
because that would be like
if failure if you got it out you would
be totally fine with dying right yeah
have you ever tried to [ __ ] for like a
while and then
eventually it's the best feeling in the
world so you'd be like bring me home
jesus you know i've done my work here
okay i want to put this on the record
just because we're putting this on the
internet it says
if you could fight one person to death
and switch lives with them only if you
win
who would it be and i'm just going to
say i just want to fight one person to
death
and that is paul dano the actor paul
dano i don't want his life i don't like
zoe kazan his wife that much either
i just want to fight you paul dano and i
want you to [ __ ] i want i want to treat
you
like [ __ ] um daniel day lewis did at
the end of there will be blood
except it's just out of spite for your
[ __ ] overacting scheme
screen whatever i don't you're dead
you're [ __ ] dead
i'll [ __ ] kill you paul dana
it says when is it okay for men to cry
and that's a hard one because i was
raised by women
and so like i don't really have my dad
uh my dad cried i think i saw my dad cry
like three times and my dad's like kind
of a
he's a dope but he's not he's not he's
like not like a tough guy but he's like
a man from the he's born in 45
i think i saw him cry like three times
and uh
one time was when he was telling me that
he was getting divorced from my mom
and the other time was when he was
telling me his dad died
and another time was when i made a toast
to him at my
first wedding that was that i talked
about him surviving cancer
so that's when i think it's okay to cry
that's it three things
three times in your life you pick them
but pick them wisely